so what exactly are the interviewers
looking for here they're looking for
personal impact for entrepreneurial
drive for problem solving skills and for
leadership so let's break that down what
does it mean what are these people
looking for so let's start with personal
impact this is really about your
achievements about the things that you
changed to the better stories about
personal impact can both be from a
business perspective or from a social
Community perspective where you created
something great for your community
entrepreneurial Drive can mean many
things but to sum it up for me in a
nutshell it means to live a bit the
normal path right to not only do the
things that are expected from you but
look for some creative ways to solve
problems